liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz unser thema an
diesem vormittag ist die
eröffnungsbilanz des klimaschutzes und
dazu begrüße ich ganz herzlich unsere
heutigen gäste das dass bundesminister
der bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz robert habeck zu meiner
rechten herzen gekommen an sie und er
hat mitgebracht staatssekretär patrick
reichen auch ein sehr herzliches
willkommen
da die bundespressekonferenz von einigen
sendern live übertragen wird
beziehungsweise auch gestreamt wird
von hier der übliche hinweis die
bundespressekonferenz ist keiner
institution der bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die
über die bundespolitik berichten unsere
aufgabe ist es pressekonferenzen zu
veranstalten damit unsere mitgliedschaft
besser die öffentlichkeit informieren
kann das als vorbemerkung und jetzt
herbig haben so das wort bitte schön ja
vielen lang kommt guten morgen von
patrick reifens und meiner seite und
vielleicht letztmalig ein frohes neues
jahr ein jahr das hoffentlich gute
gesundheit erhalten bleibt dem land ist
ermöglicht durch die verschiedenen
krisen die wir haben gut durchzukommen
und
auf konzentrierte und gute
zusammenarbeit wir haben uns hier
eingeladen oder einladen lassen in der
bundespressekonferenz um einmal mit
einem schulterblick zu starten wo wir im
bereich klimaschutz und energiepolitik
stehen um vielleicht in dieser
legislatur aus meiner sicht letztmalig
zurückzuschauen und dann den blick
beginnend mit diesem tag diese woche
komplett und konsequent nach vorne zu
richten
aber einmal müssen wir den
startpunkt noch definieren und schauen
wo wir stehen und das wird jetzt nicht
so sehr überraschen nach der
vorberichterstattung der letzten tage
wir starten nicht auf der ziellinie
sondern mit einem gehörigen rückstand
wir müssen jetzt in den nächsten
jahren effizienter und schneller werden
das tempo und die konsequenz müssen zu
nehmen im prinzip kann man über den
groben daumen sagen wir müssen dreimal
besser seien in allen bereichen nicht
die gleich nochmal abgeschiedenen
verschiedenen sektoren und sparten ein
wenn wir mit den co2 emissionen die ja
die grundlage alles tun sind beginnen so
sehen wir dass die
sondereffekte des jahres 20 die es
ermöglicht haben im jahr 2020 die
zielmarke von minus 40 prozent co2
emissionen einzuhalten im jahr 21 nicht
gewirkt haben und weg sind das heißt
strukturell sind wir deutlich schlechter
als die geplanten und vorher und
vorgegebenen ziele wir werden einen
anstieg der emissionen um vier prozent
wahrscheinlich haben darum gehen die
prognosen aus oder von 25 millionen
tonnen das heißt im jahr 21 werden wir
die emissionssenkung minus 40 prozent
deutlich verfehlen
wenn wir den pfad der bisherigen
maßnahmen fortschreiben werden wir im
jahr
2030 die zielverfehlung noch deutlicher
sehen wir werden dann 15 prozent unter
den vorher unter die minderungszielen
seien also nicht 65 prozent co2
emissionen sondern ungefähr minus 50
prozent die co2-emissionen
das ist dann in zahlen ausgedrückt 200
millionen tonnen zu viel und da wir dann
noch ein budget von 400 millionen tonnen
eigentlich haben ist es 50 prozent der
menge die wir haben drüber ich habe das
einmal mitgemacht und einer grafik dass
man das sehen keinen fall schon nicht
von hinten nicht aber das ja übertragen
wird kann man es sich hier vielleicht
ein bisschen dichter ran zoom wir sehen
hier das jahr 2020 dass es die
korea-krise der deutliche absenkung des
balkens aber es ist eben nicht politisch
induzierten oder politisch getrieben und
dann noch in der prognose die zahlen
liegen noch nicht wirklich fort aber
dann gehen sie das hier im jahr 21 dabei
wieder nach oben geht da sind wir also
und da müssen wir hin wenn man das jetzt
groß sieht sieht man dass man die
minderung sagen wir mal hier
hier gestartet der letzten
1990 also zwei balken sind wir unter
vier müssen wir runter gehen in deutlich
kürzerer zeit und den schwarzen verlauf
sehen sie hier sehen das sind die
minderung ergebnisse der bisher
beschlossenen politischen maßnahmen wenn
wir alles das umsetzen das im moment
politisch vereinbart ist nannten wir
hier und hier müssen wir sein und
hierhin zu kommen sie sehen also dass
die aufgabe groß ist
gigantisch ist
wir haben in zahlen im jahr 2010 bis 20
die emissionen in deutschland um 15
millionen tonnen senken können wir
müssen dann jährlich im durchschnitt
müssen sie
2022 bis 30 um über 40 millionen tonnen
senken das ist die der faktor drei von
dem ich gesprochen habe jetzt schon bei
den
emissionssenkungen wir haben es
geschafft in deutschland in den letzten
30 jahren die erneuerbaren energien zu
einem anteil von 42 prozent der
stromversorgung zu bringen das ist eine
leistung die man anerkennen dass
diejenigen die debatte länger verfolgt
haben können sich daran erinnern dass zu
beginn des ausbaus der erneuerbaren
gewarnt wurde das mehr als 34 5 prozent
anteil der erneuerbaren das stromsystem
überhaupt nicht verkraften könnte nun
sind wir 30 jahre später bei über 40
prozent
aber wir haben dafür 30 jahre gebraucht
und wir haben noch acht jahre zeit den
anteil nach plan der bundesregierung
nach koalitionsvertrag auf 80 prozent zu
bringen also 30 jahre gut 40 prozent
acht jahre um dann das doppelte noch mal
zu machen dabei sind bisher in den
berechnungen die steigenden strombedarf
nicht eingepreist worden in deutschland
verbraucht ungefähr 500 60
terawattstunden strom pro jahr das wird
aber steigen durch rollout der
wärmepumpen durch hochlauf der
e-mobilität wir werden dann ungefähr bei
7 100 terawattstunden jährlich liegen
die schätzungen reichen von 680 bis 750
also die 80 prozent bezogen den
strombedarf ist eben noch mal bezogen
auf eine größere menge was die aufgabe
nur noch größer macht bedrückend ist
dass der trend in die falsche richtung
geht wir haben über die letzten drei
jahre ein zubau von offshore-wind das
ist würde ich sagen doch einmal der
lastesel der erneuerbaren energien von
einem gigawatt gehabt viel zu wenig
offshore ist nahezu komplett zum
erliegen gekommen
man sieht es hier beim anteil der ich
habe es noch mal mitgebracht beim anteil
der erneuerbaren am bruttostromverbrauch
das ist da wo wir sind sie sehen sogar
dass wir im letzten jahr ein zurückgehen
haben dass du wird man auch hinten
erkennen können hier geht es immer nicht
steil genug immer unbedingt aber es geht
immer bergauf sondern auch einmal geht
es vergab in einem jahr wo wir
eigentlich die kehrtwende nun wirklich
einleiten müssen haben wir den anteil am
bruttostromverbrauch
eine bayern heuer waren noch geringer
und sie sehen wie schnell die kurve dann
nach oben gehen muss das ist der faktor
drei von dem ich gesprochen habe
hier sehen sie dann noch einmal in den
grafiken das was ich gesagt habe den
zubau von wind und photovoltaik das ist
der super von wind das dunkelblaue ist
auch schon hier wurde auch schon okay zu
gebaut würde ich seine - runter und die
letzten jahre wurde überhaupt nicht mehr
auch schon zugebaut
hier ging es ganz gut los und das sind
die letzten jahre gewesen hier sind wir
das ist prognosen dessen was wir
erreichen müssen in den nächsten jahren
also sehen die sich die zahlen an das
sind die jahre des maximalen zubaus
gewesen als es richtig gut ging und
sehen sie sich an was wir erreichen
müssen bei photovoltaik ist die tendenz
ein bisschen besser sie sehen dass es
bei niedrigen jahren hier dann leicht
aufwärts gegangen ist aber gemessen an
dem was wir machen müssen ist selbst das
okay zu war würde ich sagen nur die
startrampe hier müssen wir hin und das
kulminiert ist dann der zubau der
erneuerbaren energien über die nächsten
jahre die wir leisten müssen
um den strombedarf und den anteil den
wir dafür habe decken zu können
wenn wir uns anschauen woran es hapert
dann sind die gründe vielfältig vor
allem ist bei onshore festzustellen dass
die fläche einfach schlichtweg nicht da
ist um diese mengen zu zu bauen brauchen
wir zwei prozent der bundesdeutschen
fläche gute nachricht ist 98 prozent der
fläche sind freizuhalten und werden auch
nicht gebraucht
ausgewiesen theoretisch sind 0,8 prozent
faktisch zur verfügung stehen 0,5 also
das was sie erleben ist ein viertel
dessen was wir kennen ein viertel dessen
was wir tatsächlich brauchen einige
flächen sind natürlich mit alten anlagen
bestellt das sind auch häufig die serbin
starken flächen das heißt über das
repowering schonen wir die fläche und
haben trotzdem einen guten zubau von
leistung aber wir brauchen mehr fläche
völlig klar ich verzichte jetzt heute
hier darauf die länder einzeln
durchzugehen bin aber mit den
landesregierungen in kontakt und suche
den kontakt und werde ich auch
persönlich besuchen um das dann einzeln
durch zu sprechen aber es gibt nur zwei
länder die in die nähe des 2 prozent
ziels kommen das sind hessen und
schleswig-holstein alle anderen ligen
darunter und dann muss man jetzt nicht
lange um den heißen brei herum liegen da
werden einige gespräche zu führen sein
und das wird ein mühsamer prozess werden
allerdings auf die mühsam kite des
prozesses nicht zu einer zeitlichen
verzögerung führen wir müssen die
flächen schaffen sonst kommen wir da
nicht dran und alle müssen mithelfen
dass wir diese flächen schaffen wenn man
sich anschaut was weiterhin passieren
sollte man in die verschiedenen sektoren
reingeht wir reden ja beim klimaschutz
jetzt nicht mehr alleine vom strommarkt
also dem ausbau von photovoltaik und
wind sondern auch über industrie über
mobilität über wärme so ein paar zahlen
und zu verdeutlichen was ansteht alleine
für den jährlichen verbrauch der
stahlindustrie wenn sie auf grünen stahl
umstellt werden 15 terawattstunden
wasserstoff 2030 benötigt 3
terawattstunden wasserstoff sind bisher
bundesweit für alle sektoren in der
planung und geplant also wir brauchen
einen massiven hochlauf von wasserstoff
wir wollen ein rollout der wärmepumpen
also stromgetriebenen die dann aber
dafür sorgen dass die wärmeversorgung
erneuerbar ist auf vier bis sechs
millionen das ist eine vervierfachung
der bisherigen zahlen und planungen
wir haben beschlossen und das ist schon
ja auch berichtet worden den hochlauf
der e mobilität auf 15 millionen
fahrzeuge
2030 das bedeutet dann aber auch hinter
konsequenz dass wir jährlich 100.000
neue ladepunkte brauchen eine große
infrastruktur aufgabe die da auf uns
zukommt und
mir das alles zusammen nehmen steht das
land vor einer großen politischen
debatte hier in der
bundespressekonferenz kann man die
zahlen referieren und die grafiken
hochhalten und die kameras klicken und
man sagt okay ganz schön sportliche
aufgabe das wird mal interessant werden
wie das anzugehen ist wenn man dann im
land unterwegs ist weiß man dass mit
diesen zahlen nicht nur eine technische
debatte verknüpft ist sondern eine
soziale debatte eine debatte die die
kulturelle identität von räumen betrifft
der zubau von erneuerbaren energien
macht etwas mit dem ländlichen raum eine
debatte die das verhältnis von stadt als
großen verbrauchszentren oder
industriezentren und ländlichen raum neu
betrifft eine debatte die ost west nord
süd in den verschiedenen kompetenzen und
auch debatten lagen und politischen
mehrheiten betrifft also man muss sich
keine illusionen darüber machen dass es
eben nicht nur eine technische frage ist
sondern auch eine frage ist die tief in
die gesellschaftliche wirklichkeit
eingreift und nur dann gewonnen werden
kann wenn sie auch als gesellschaftliche
debatte geführt werden wird ich
jedenfalls werde versuchen das so
aufzusetzen
um das ganze in gang zu bringen haben
wir uns ein ehrgeiziges arbeitsprogramm
gesetzt wir planen zwei große
artikelgesetz pakete dass eine an eine
art oster paket im frühjahr an soll die
sofort wirksamen maßnahmen bündeln dann
im frühjahr um ostern herum durch
kabinett so dass dann die
parlamentarischen befassung bis zur
sommerpause abgeschlossen sind einiges
von denen wird dann beihilfe pflichtig
sein muss in europa genehmigt werden
aber das was prioritäre wirksamkeit
entfaltet muss alles in
2022 erledigt sein damit es in 23
wirksam wird ich gehe gleich noch mal
ein bisschen durch nun planen wir einen
sommer paket wird an die weiteren
prioritären maßnahmen die dann wirksam
werden und die schlechten die
fördermöglichkeiten die neuen
gesetzlichen normen darstellen dann in
der zweiten jahreshälfte ebenfalls sich
das parlamentarische verfahren bringen
also oster und sommer paket sind
begriffe für die kabinettsbefassung die
dann in den verfahren die nachgelagert
sind parlamentarische befassung im
bundestag gegebenenfalls in den
landesparlamenten im bundesrat oder
notifizierung in der eu noch in 22
möglich machen
ein paar bereiche kann man
identifizieren die jetzt sofort
angegangen werden müssen quasi mit
diesem schulterblick des heutigen tages
zurück dann blickt nach vorne das ist
die neue aufstellung des eeg noch dann
ihren oster paket mit der erhöhung der
ausschreibung entsprechend des 80
prozent ziels wie eben in der grafik
vorgestellt mit der definition der
überragenden öffentlichen bedeutung der
erneuerbaren energien das ist ja das was
im koalitionsvertrag noch mal
festgeschrieben wurde was sich aber
logisch ergibt wenn wir die erneuerbaren
energien zum rückgrat der
energieversorgung machen dann sind sie
sicherheitsrelevant und müssen auch so
behandelt werden auch in der schutz
güterabwägung gegenüber anderen
schutzgüter und der abschaffung der eeg
umlage wir werden zweitens ein solar
beschleunigungs paket auf den weg
bringen so dass dinge wie großzügigere
nutzung von mieter strom aber auch die
solarpflicht neue flächen für
freiflächen pv und bessere fördersätze
dort vereinbart werden so dass hier zu
einem rollout der pv der solaranlagen in
deutschland noch einmal kommen werden
drittens dann die maßnahmen ergreifen
die genehmigte fläche für
windkraftanlagen hoffentlich schneller
zu einer bebauung führen können wir
haben in deutschland in der summe acht
bis neun gigawatt gigawatt kann man sich
merken essen grunde ein
atomkraftwerk in der kapazität
genehmigten flächen da könnt ihr also
gebaut werden die aber aufgrund von
anderen shootern oder gütern belegt sind
das sind vor allem radaranlagen des
deutschen wetterdienstes oder der
deutschen flugsicherung für analoge dre
funkfeuer also eine sehr alte technik
die als backup vorgehalten wird und
flächen wo die bundeswehr sagt da kann
nicht gebaut werden aus
sicherheitsüberlegungen
die haben natürlich alle in sich ihre
mehr oder weniger starke berechtigung
aber wir müssen da vorankommen und ich
bin mit den kollegen in guten gespräch
und hoffe dass wir kurzfristig dort
flächen frei räumen können so dass der
ausbau dann wieder wenigstens auf dem
genehmigten flächen in gang kommt da
sind wir noch gar nicht mehr artenschutz
und naturschutzflächen verfahren das
sind einfach nur flächen die eigentlich
zur verfügung stehen wo es eine
konkurrenz abwägung oder eine
güterabwägung gibt die noch mal neu
vorzunehmen sein wird dann das
winterland gesetz das wird sicherlich
eine kompliziertere operation das ist
das was sich hinter dem zwei prozent
ziel verbirgt wir wollen mit dem oster
paket die sogenannten kontrakt kabeln
contract for difference is verträge das
sind die förderverträge für die
industrie auf den weg bringen im grunde
der logik nach wenn jetzt die industrie
sich auf den weg machte den
verschiedenen sparten beispielsweise
wasserstoff einzusetzen und die höhere
kosten hat gibt es einen vertrag mit der
öffentlichen hand diese mehrkosten zu
erstatten wenn aber beispielsweise durch
einen höheren co2 preis die neue technik
sich rechnet also die produktion auf
einmal günstiger wird zahlt wird ein
stück jedenfalls der fördermaßnahmen
zurückgezahlt all das soll programmiert
werden das löst dann die bremse bei den
investitionen der industrie dass die
sicherheit für die investition und wird
zu den entsprechenden umbaumaßnahmen in
der industrie führen wir werden die
wärme strategie auflegen die vor allem
über die kommunale wärme planung
dann dafür zu führen soll dass wir ab
2025 65 prozent erneuerbare energie für
alle neue heizanlagen haben werden dazu
gehören auch fördermaßnahmen für die
fernwärmenetze also da wo es
verbundsysteme kann man ja gebündelt
energie reinen führen wir setzen vor
allem darauf dass ein förderprogramm das
gerade in der notifizierung bei der eu
liegt das baby das bundesprogramm für
effiziente wärmenetze einen großen
effekt hat sodass wir auch
beispielsweise industrielle abwärme
stärker in die fernwärmenetze reinnehmen
werden und über den rollout der gruppen
habe ich schon gesprochen noch drei
punkte gebäude energie gesetz neu
aufzusetzen also die effizienz kriterien
für bauen und sanieren hochzusetzen
gleichzeitig die förderung anzupassen
und sowohl die sanierung wie auch die
versorgung mit erneuerbaren energien neu
abzuwägen ist teil der pakete die
wasserstoff strategie muss neu aufgelegt
werden in den drei bestandteilen
förderung
infrastruktur und beschaffung von
wasserstoff beschaffung heißt sowohl
importe von wasserstoff wie vereinbaren
zu verändern sind wir aber auch
standorte für elektrolyse zu
identifizieren also da wo große mengen
erneuerbarer strom in deutschland
verfügbar sind das sind ideale standorte
um dann noch einmal wasserstoff in
deutschland in erneuerbare energien in
deutschland in wasserstoff umzuwandeln
und
[Musik]
all das zusammen macht diese genannten
oster und sondern packte aus insgesamt
mit dem blick zurück über die schulter
wo wir stehen und den abfallenden kurven
der blick nach vorne es ist eine große
politische aufgabe aber eine die
natürlich auch für das land eine enorme
chance bereithält und für die politische
kultur eine enorme chance bereithält
wenn wir sie bestehen diese aufgabe wenn
wir das angehen werden wir darüber zu
einem neuen verhältnis von bund und land
kommen also die föderale das föderale
zusammenspiel besser machen können wir
werden unsere industrie erneuern und die
industrie erneuern heißt eben auch
wertschöpfung arbeitsplätze
wohlstand für mittelstand und handwerk
bereitstellen zu können wir werden
wieder
innovationsland sein und wir werden
bürokratie und planungsprozesse
schlanker machen müssen und können
dadurch wir werden also lernen wie wir
besser werden und was gibt es für eine
bessere aufgabe politisch zu
verantworten zu lernen wie man besser
werden kann ich jedenfalls und das haus
bei dem ich mich herzlich bedanken das
ist in sehr kurzer zeit diesen soliden
berichten liegt ihm jetzt ja vor dreißig
seiten ungefähr was ich hier in dürren
worten vorgestellt habe erarbeitet haben
und gleichzeitig darüber hinaus schon in
die planung der gesetzesentwürfe
eingetreten ist wie jedenfalls sind
voller energie die sich täglich erneuert
weil wir an diesem großen projekt
mitarbeiten können dankeschön herzlichen
dank herr beck dann kommen wir zu fragen
ich habe allerdings schon eine liste von
über
20 wortmeldungen online nach ihrem saal
wir werden das nicht schaffen denn gegen
korona müssen wir dann auch irgendwann
beizeiten lüften das wird so etwa nach
einer stunde seien insofern bitte ich um
einhaltung unserer regel eine frage eine
nachfrage
und nicht noch das zu versuchen in
mehrere fragen zu packen dann kommen wir
schnell voran dankeschön und die erste
fragesteller ist herr koch
vielleicht macht es auch sinn nochmal
sich vorzustellen weil vielleicht habe
ich noch nicht alle kollegen hier kennt
aber viele
wir können das einmal vorstellen ich bin
robert habeck
hallo hannes kraft die courts und in
unter anderem für die tageszeitung taz
und ein original zeitung
würde gerne fragen zum thema
gasversorgung was halten sie von
rechnungen die leistung der kraftwerke
in deutschland verdoppelt werden muss
und 20 und 40 gw ungefährt in den
nächsten zehn jahren
wir brauchen für den übergang
gaskraftwerke das ist völlig unstrittig
und wir brauchen nach dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren eine kraftwerks
infrastruktur die als backup kapazität
für spitzenleistungen zur verfügung
steht bzw auch für tage mit wenig
sonneneinstrahlung und wenig wind die
versorgungssicherheit dann
übergangsweise gewährleisten kann das
ist völlig klar die infrastruktur ist zu
trennen von dem brennstoff dann das ist
ja auch das was taxonomische vereinbart
wurde und das was auch die ziele der
koalition sind ab 35 ansteigend soll der
future erfolgen und dann soll ob
wasserstoff erneuerbaren wasserstoff
umgestellt werden aber wir brauchen ein
hochfahren der kapazitäten
ob es eine verdoppelung ist ob es ob man
das anders berechnen muss also es soll
ja nicht kohle durch gas ersetzt werden
dann hat man das gleiche und die laufen
tag und nacht so ist es ja nicht gedacht
sondern sie so flexibel geführt werden
das kann ich jetzt hier nicht über die
pressekonferenz zu rufen das sind die
ziele rechnungen an denen wir sind und
die dann über das jahr erstellt werden
und gleichzeitig mit dem übergang oder
mit dem ausbau der kapazitäten die jetzt
unter gaskraftwerken formieren der
aufbau einer wasserstoff-infrastruktur
die er noch komplizierter ist als jetzt
für diesen ja immer knapper werdenden
markt gas soll dann ja oder die fossilen
oder didi didi brennstoff betriebenen
kraftwerke sollen dann ja in der in der
laufzeit und in der menge
teuerung immer geringer werden den
hochlauf der wasserstoff infrastruktur
zu bauen ist ein großes unterfangen aber
ja also die probe antwort ist wir werden
mehr gaskraftwerke brauchen und die
entsprechende infrastruktur die dann
zunehmend in den 30er jahren auf
wasserstoff umgestellt werden soll
und diese gaskraftwerke werden auch bei
man laufen
die werden zunehmend als reserve
kapazitäten vorgehalten werden mit dem
hochlaufen der erneuerbaren energien
aber dann lasten abfedern
wie gesagt in den sogenannten dunkel
flaute zeiten bzw bei sehr hohen bedarf
wo der bedarf noch nicht erneuerbar
gedeckt werden kann aber mit dem ausbau
der erneuerbaren werden sie immer
punktuell eingesetzt werden
die nächste frage wen ich
habe persönlich von der deutschen
presse-agentur herbig haben von einer
großen politischen debatte gesprochen
und gibt es ja große akzeptanzprobleme
gerade beim ausbau der windkraft an land
sie haben anfang dezember auch von einer
zumutung gesprochen oder gesagt die
energiewende geht wird nicht ohne zu gut
und geht in diesem zusammenhang jetzt
die frage welche botschaft fanden sie
dann in sachen akzeptanz an die bürger
so viele gegen gegen neue windräder sind
und das land kann man nur die botschaft
senden dass die erneuerbaren teil der
lösung sind und zwar von verschiedenen
problemen einerseits natürlich unser
beitrag die klimakrise zu
einzudämmen jedenfalls beherrschbar zu
halten und damit auch den auftrag des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes freiheit zu
bewahren umzusetzen
energiepolitisch weil es uns in weiten
bereichen unabhängiger macht von jahr
das sehen wir ja in diesem winter
schwankenden
globalen fossilen märkten
und
wirtschaftspolitisch weil damit ein
hochlaufen von innovationen
wertschöpfung und arbeitsplätzen
verbunden ist etwas was wir in diesem
land langer zeit ja auch nicht so
gesehen haben
[Musik]
natürlich im detail
immer dann wenn
in windkraftanlagen oder stromtrassen
gebaut werden
jetzt kann ich sagen
sind die ausführungen ich eben gemacht
haben natürlich wenig wert weil dann
leute sagen ja das mache alles schön und
gut aber bitte nicht da ich immer am
sonntag spazieren mit meinem waldi und
früher als ich kind war haben wir immer
dort gespielt und da soll jetzt eine
stromleitung sein oder die bauern
beklagen sich darüber dass die leitung
als erdkabel verlegt werden also immer
individuelle betroffenheiten gibt es und
die summe der individuellen
betroffenheit und verhindert dann häufig
das
gemeinschaftlich und volkswirtschaftlich
sinnvolle das ist klar und aus der
individuelle betroffenheit heraus
natürlich
nachzuvollziehen erst einmal hoffe ich
dass wir als gesellschaft in der lage
sind auch hin und wieder mal über
unseren eigenen individuellen
betroffenheits schatten zu springen
sonst wird das alles nichts werden also
solidarität heißt dann eben auch dass
man sich bereit erklärt das was
gemeinschaftlich als richtig erkannt
wurde und politische art verabredet
wurde mit zu tragen und das sind aber
natürlich nur erstmal grundsätzlich auch
moralische appelle ich denke dass mit
dem ausbau von windkraft aber das gilt
eben auch für freiflächen pv-anlagen
sich auch ökonomische vorteile für die
region und für die menschen in der
region verbinden müssen das kann über
direkte beteiligung an diesem parks
erfolgen das sind der große investments
die notwendig sind wenn man das in
teilen jedenfalls als bürger energie
aufsetzen kann gewinnen menschen auch
dadurch so ist es auch mal gedacht
gewesen dass sich mit der
dezentralisierung der
energieinfrastruktur auch eine
demokratisierung also eine teilhabe der
menschen am energiesystem verwirklichen
lässt das sind bürger windparks oder
bürgersolaranlagen die man aufbauen kann
etwas was heute schon fast altmodisch
klingt da wo das
nicht gewollt oder nicht
möglich ist können dann die kommunen
davon sehr profitieren und das ist
vielleicht das ökonomisch
interessanteste an dieser situation dass
damit sich auch wertschöpfung im
ländlichen raum verbinden kann und
vielleicht gerade in den ländlichen
räumen wie sonst mit wertschöpfung nicht
zu besonders gesegnet sind solche
anlagen ziehen meistens große
investitionen in den internet in den
glasfaserausbau nach sich die handeln an
der leipziger strombörse
häufig sind die schnellsten regionen im
ländlichen raum für internet anbindungen
da wo große ausbau von erneuerbaren ist
ich verbinde sich damit wertschöpfung
von wartung häufig auch von anderen
mobilitätsformen und immer stärker gehen
wirtschaftsbetriebe in regionen wo sie
ihre unternehmungen mit grüner energie
befeuern können also die batterie
hersteller die wir jetzt zunehmend in
deutschland ansiedeln wollen nicht nur
batterien für e mobile produzieren sie
wollen die batterien auch mit grünem
strom produzieren und damit grüner
energie produzieren das ist also eine
nachfrage die dann da ist so dass sich
damit auch das ja nicht für die region
für die bundesländer das versprechen von
neuen bachelor fonds ketten verbindet
die summe aus allem dass es dann geben
und ich werde viel im land unterwegs
sein um zu versuchen die menschen zu
überzeugen
vielleicht kurz der nachfrage zu dem
thema abstandsregelungen da gibt es ja
höchst unterschiedliche regelungen in
bayern die berühmte 10h regel die müsste
dann ersatzlos quasi streichen oder was
haben sie da konkret vor beim thema
abstandsregeln das ist ein wesentlicher
punkt bei sprechen ziel
da wo abstandsregeln vorgehalten werden
um verhinderungsplanung zu wird
schreiben können die nicht länger
bestehen bleiben
die nächste frage ist
dann grimm von der augsburger morgen
habe ich hätte eine frage sie haben
angekündigt dass im jahr 2030 millionen
elektrofahrzeuge auf unseren straßen
werden unterwegs sein müssen deutlich
mehr als heute wie wird die ampel
koalition bezüglich der förderung
reagieren wird diese förderung auch bis
2030 laufen können die wir jetzt den
käufern von elektroautos gewähren nicht
in der gleichen höhe wir haben für 2022
für dieses jahr die sogenannte
innovations- prämie und den öko bonus
verlängert das heißt im moment ist die
förderungen voller höhe da wir haben
aber auch angekündigt dass wir
einsteigen mit 223 die förderung stärker
auf die tatsächlich elektrische leistung
konzentrieren werden das heißt sie wird
sich stärker auf immobilie fokussieren
und bei denen hybridfahrzeugen dann an
der elektrischen laufleistung festmachen
mit dem hochlauf mit der marktgängigkeit
ist ja auch eine kostendegression
verbunden die fahrzeuge werden
perspektivisch günstiger werden in dem
maße kann man auch die förderung
zurückgefahren werden wir werden geld
aber gut an anderer stelle brauchen
können das ist jetzt hier nicht so dass
der bundeshaushalt zu lasten derjenigen
die sich auf umweltfreundliche mobilität
einlassen spannend wie gesagt das sind
denke ich
dass das das system passt gut zueinander
und wir sehen das ja jetzt schon dass
die elektromobilität sich einer hohen
nachfrage
erfreut und beliebt umgekehrt werden wir
enorme gelder
[Musik]
aufsetzen müssen um die anderen bereiche
gängig zu machen wärmepumpen die
industrie förderung den hochlauf der
wasserstoff-infrastruktur
ich möchte eine frage online einfügen
arne delfs von bloomberg fragt
angesichts der rasant steigenden
energiepreise gibt es forderungen das
subventionen für privatverbraucher und
unternehmen wie vertragen sich
staatliche subventionen für fossile
energien mit ihrem ziel der energiewende
vereinbart haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag eine reihe von punkten
die die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
entlasten
ich habe schon gesagt dass zu diesen
oster paket die novellierung des
erneuerbaren energien gesetzes gehört
mit der abschaffung der umlage die dann
ab 23 wirksam werden wird nach dem vieh
zierung der eu und übrigens auch eine
menge von bürokratischen
locken wird wieder helfen abschneiden zu
lassen
dass wir hätten eine entlastung der
verbraucher von ungefähr 300 euro im
durchschnittlichen haushalt in
deutschland
sozialpolitische maßnahmen sind
ebenfalls vereinbart worden im
koalitionsvertrag und werden jetzt in
den anderen ressorts umgesetzt für
diejenigen die mindestlohn bereich sind
und die natürlich bei hohen
energiepreisen weil nicht zu opulenten
einkommen hart getroffen sind der höhere
mindestlohn ist führt höhere sätze im
wohngeld und bei hartz4 geben die den
kosten hochlauf dann ein stück weit
kompensieren können und für die
vermieter haben wir vereinbart dass wir
ein teil der co2 umlage auf die auf die
miete für die wieder haben wir
vereinbart dass wir ein teil der co2
anlage auf die wärme bei vermieteten
objekten auf die vermieter übertragen es
gibt also sozial politische flankierung
darüber hinaus wäre zu überprüfen
inwieweit der
energiemarkt der ja sehr dereguliert ist
und einen teil der hohen strom- und
gaskosten die jetzt vor dem verbraucher
tragen liegt eben auch daran dass es ein
ein discounter angebot gibt im
strombereich das dann auf einmal jetzt
nicht mehr funktioniert und die leute
fallen aus den verträgen raus und gehen
ihnen die grundversorgung zurück und
müssen dann weil die grundversorgern
nicht mit denen kalkuliert haben höhere
preise bekommen ob das für die zukunft
einfach so sein kann oder ob man da
nicht eine zweite oder dritte sicherungs
linie einbauen muss das wird zu prüfen
sein ich bin der meinung dass man
reformen bedarf braucht aber das hilft
dann nicht mehr für das jahr 2000 oder
für den winter 21 22 sondern greift dann
im besten fall 22 23 die nächste war
jung bitte der junge lief er weg zwei
fragen was soll die eine frage der junge
da fragt was soll hier jetzt ihr großer
wurf sein angesichts der von ihnen
vorgetragenen
rückstände habe ich verstanden dass es
einen großen wurf braucht aber was ist
da jetzt erst noch mal erklären der
große wurf ist die arbeit dieser
legislatur
zu setzen und habe ich sie vorhin
richtig verstanden dass sie als mitglied
der bundesregierung auch anerkennen dass
deutschland ein finales co2 budget hat
das wäre was neues
es gibt einen vereinbarten emissionstag
- 65 prozent - 88
2040 der alten bundesregierung wir haben
die zahlen nicht eingehoben aber daraus
ergibt sich logischerweise das ist ein
co2 budget gibt das sich in den gesetzen
widerspiegelt - 88 prozent co2 muss ja
eine fixe ausgangsgröße haben von 1990
ausgerechnet und die reduktionsziele
sind dann nur noch mathematik ja klar
herr polenz
martin polansky hauptschule wenn es
derart weg ich hätte in der konkrete
frage zu den überragenden öffentlichen
interesse das soll er ein wichtiges
mittel sein um das zu beschleunigen den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien aus
ihrer sicht was ändert sich damit
konkret was heißt es dann auch für
klagemöglichkeiten für die bürger
überhaupt die bürgerbeteiligung
es ändert sich dann vor allem konkret in
der genehmigung von anlagen die abwägung
von schutzgüter wenn windkraftanlagen in
diesem fall aber das kann übertragen
auch für pv anlagen geplant werden dann
machen die haben ordnungsbehörden der
länder weisen flächen aus dann wird
schon da eine vor abwägung getroffen ob
es überlappende kriterien gibt die diese
flächen als nicht gut geplant war
darstellen und so kommt man dann zu
flächen und in der genehmigung selbst
werden dann die anlagen geprüft auf
emissionsschutz rechtliche genehmigung
auf
sichtbeeinträchtigung
geräusche auf artenschutzrechtliche
kriterien gehen noch einmal wieder neue
gefunden werden können und in der
abwägung der behörden würde dieses
überragende öffentliche interesse dazu
führen dass andere schutzgüter
nachrangig beurteilt werden das wäre
erst einmal im genehmigungsverfahren der
große vorteil dass dann nicht mehr
schutzgüter gleich nebeneinander stehen
sondern sie in der abwägung nachrangig
sein können
und für die
für die bundespolitische planung heißt
es eben dass die beim netzausbau
beispielsweise wo so verfahren wurde
dann auch zügiger genehmigt werden kann
meiner auffassung nach
zusatz nachfrage noch mal zur
bürgerbeteiligung heißt es dann auch
verkürzte klagewege beziehungsweise dann
auch die instanzen liege dass die
verkürzt werden oder wie es scheint sich
der bürgerbeteiligung vor wenn es ein
überragendes natürlichen 30 das ist erst
einmal ist es eine anweisung für die
genehmigung das habe ich ja gesagt und
dann wie die klage installation
aufgebaut werden können dort man
verfahren bündeln kann das kann man
meiner auffassung nach ob man bei
bestimmten
verfahren in die sogenannte legal
planung einsteigt das also große
infrastrukturprojekte dann
parlamentarisch beschlossen werden was
dann die beschleunigung ebenfalls nach
sich ziehen würde
das wird im einzelfall jetzt diskutiert
werden aber in der summe müssen wir
schneller werden ich will immer noch
sagen aus der erfahrung auch ein
bisschen ich habe ja diesen ausbau von
windkraft und stromnetzen schon ein paar
jahren hauptberuflich betrieben mit
meiner amtszeit in schleswig-holstein
dass bürgerbeteiligung auf zwei arten zu
verstehen ist häufig ist es eine formale
bürgerbeteiligung das heißt dass die
planungsunterlagen ausgelegt werden im
internet vorgehalten werden in
amtsstuben in akten stehen dann kann man
sagen ja du hast jetzt zwei jahre zeit
die das anzuschauen und einwendungen zu
erheben
das tun einige aber nicht häufig die
bürger die kriegen das gar nicht mit
bürgerbeteiligung zweitens ist man
erklärt das projekt man geht dahin man
redet mit den menschen man stellt sich
der debatte man erläutert was notwendig
ist das ist dann ein informelles
verfahren wenn sie so wollen aber häufig
das viel wichtigere weil dann diskutiert
werden kann weil man sich dann nicht
über paragrafen austausch sondern sich
in die augen geguckt und dann genau die
geschichten passieren die ich eben kurz
angerissen habe dass man sagt ich bin
schon für den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien aber doch bitte nicht da weil
da meine kinder immer im wald spielen
und bitte nicht da weil ich da immer mit
meinem mit meiner großmutter unterwegs
denn weil wir nur sie dahin bei aus der
uns alles gut und dann findet man
möglicherweise eine lösung und ich
glaube dass man dieses mehr oder weniger
bürgerbeteiligung mal ein bisschen
aufdröseln müssen kann ein
bundesminister nicht mit allen 80
millionen bürgern in deutschland
einzelnen reden aber man kann sicherlich
sich bemühen bestimmte projekte
formal zu beschleunigen durch bündelung
der verfahren durch die schnelle
öffentliche
umsetzung der verfahren ohne weniger
bürgerbeteiligung damit herzuleiten
sondern trotzdem die menschen zu
beteiligen und wir werden in meinem
ministerium auf diesen aspekt besonders
viel achtsamkeit legen dafür eigene
kompetenzen bereitstellen weil die
übersetzung von
technischen daten und politischen
planung und gesetzlichen normen in
normale wirklichkeit in alltägliche
sprache im
küchentisch tauglichen debatten die
entscheidende frage ist darüber ob es
gelingt über diese verschiedenen punkte
gesellschaftlich immer eine
mehrheitsfähige position zu erlangen und
das strebe ich an
dann habe ich als nächsten frage stelle
herrn brücke
minister michael brücker media panel
zubau erneuerbarer energien für viele
experten dass diese 80 prozent will
eigentlich nur erreichbar wenn sie die
solarpflicht die sie für gewerbe
neubauten planen eigentlich auch für die
privaten eigentümer liebte warten
einfamilienhäuser stärker heranziehen
wie es in einigen bundesländern ja auch
der fall ist ist das was geht da noch
was wird dann ihrem gesetz sein und gibt
es bei den zwei wind flächen bei den
ländern eigentlich auch so eine art
windkraftanlagen zertifikate handel
zwischen den ländern also geografische
bedingungen unterschiedlich sind dass
nicht jedes land zwei prozent erreichen
muss
für den neubau von privathäusern ist im
koalitionsvertrag ebenfalls ein sollen
verabredet das heißt man wird mit guten
gründen auch
argumentieren können warum das in diesem
fall nicht funktioniert aber die
erwartung ist dass auch der neubau von
privaten häusern in der regel mit
solaranlagen auf dem dach passiert wie
wir das genau baurecht nicht umsetzen
werden wir mit der kollegin klara
geywitz keilwitz demnächst besprechen
und
für den bestand wiederum wird man gucken
ob man nicht interessante nutzungsformen
von solarenergie findet dies wieder
attraktiver machen für menschen dort
einzusteigen
die zwei prozent das haben sie richtig
gesagt heißen nicht
automatisch dass jedes land 2% zu bauen
muss aber die summe muss im durchschnitt
erzielt werden und wenn die länder
untereinander zu absprachen kommen die
sich gegenseitig entlasten dass eine
nachbarland macht 2,5 das andere nur 1,5
dafür gibt es aber irgendwelche anderen
möglichkeiten auf der föderalen ebenen
anderen politikbereichen zum ausgleich
zu kommen so soll mir das recht sein am
ende brauchen wir die fläche und wenn
ich das jetzt ein bisschen öffnen uns
sage die föderale ordnung sieht ja sehr
viel eigenständigkeit der länder vor und
die ministerpräsidentin
ministerpräsidenten sind sehr
selbstbewusste kolleginnen und kollegen
alle schätze ich dann müssen sie sich
ihrer verantwortung leben auch stellen
das gerne gemeinsam hinbekommen unsere
aufgabe ist allerdings dafür zu sorgen
dass am ende die zahl stimmt und das
heißt es kann keinen wettlauf nach unten
geben es kann keine politik geben wo
jemand sagt ich musste mich damit ich
beteilige mich möglichst nicht damit bei
mir ist das nicht möglich das ist die
falsche herangehensweise und wie gesagt
ich plane jetzt
einmal würde ich gerne alle bundesländer
bereist haben mit einem den kollegen die
die energie und wirtschaftspolitik
verantworten darüber gesprochen haben
wenn es geht mit den ministerpräsidenten
so dass wir da parallel zu dem prozess
auf der bundesebene auch im geist einer
gemeinsamkeit vorankommen mal gucken was
die sagen zum klimaschutz bekannt haben
sie sich ja alle
dann hab ich als nächste fragestellerin
die kollegen ganz hinten
auch so eine kommission erneuerbare
energien damit sie auch die
naturschutzbehörden antwort bekommen
werden die sind ja eben auch
eine hürde bei dem ganzen sind an land
ausbauen
ich plane es keine extra kommission es
gibt ja die verschiedenen gesprächs
formate und zu all den verbänden sowohl
zu den verbänden der wirtschaft der
erneuerbaren wie zu den
naturschutzverbänden haben wir enge
arbeitsbeziehungen das schließt
ausdrücklich mit ein dass es sein kann
dass man sich mal zusammen setzt einen
tag lang eine klausur macht die
verschiedenen stakeholder heißt es ist
glaube ich immer plattdeutsch immer alle
gemeinsam in einem raum bringt und sagte
wir müssen ja irgendwie weiterkommen
aber
aufgabenbezogen oder problemen bezogen
würde ich vorgehen ich plane jetzt nicht
und möchte das auch gerne nicht die
verantwortung zu delegieren und zu sagen
was ich habe ein riesengroßes
ministerbüro es irgend möglich
riesengroß da fühle ich mich so wohl
drin und ihr arbeitet mal bitte und
präsentiert in anderthalb jahren die
ergebnisse einer kommission dass nun
nicht wie immer man das nennen was ich
vorhabe ich verstehe kommission als
auslagerung der verantwortung in diesem
fall das möchte ich nicht wir werden das
eng führen noch ein politisch führen und
dann die kolleginnen und kollegen aus
den verschiedenen bereichen und spaten
immer dann zusammentrommeln nennen wir
sie brauchen aber der arbeits kontaktes
intensiv und nicht nur von meiner seite
sondern von patrick reichen und den
anderen kollegen jeder unterwegs sind
dann fragt jens peter paul von 7 tv
herbeck warum fällt ihnen erst jetzt auf
das gleichzeitige auto ausstieg und co2
ausstieg nicht zusammen passen sie
hatten noch mindestens zehn jahre zeit
darüber nachzudenken und sich einen
funktionierenden auch gar nicht über
atompolitik heute gesprochen insofern
verstehe ich den auslöser der frage
nicht und den funktionierenden plan habe
ich gerade vorgestellt
dann als nächste frage herr wackelt
name ist wackelt von reuters ich hab
noch mal eine frage zu onshore wind da
steht er im koalitionsvertrag keine zahl
aber was meine leistung kapazität mann
kommen will bis 20.30 und sie haben
angekündigt dass also die ausschreibungs
mengen zu erhöhen von einem höheren
natur auch wenn ja
wo starten wir dann nicht und sie viel
lernen insgesamt werden noch schauen
die sonst üblichen den zahlen
also das ist aber in dieser grafik die
galle hoch gehalten wurde grob
dargestellt
dann gucke ich mir auch die zahlen hier
ist der zubau in gigawatt ja dargestellt
wir sind hier bei 5 gigawatt die dann
jährlich anwachsen also in
22 wenn alles einigermaßen funktioniert
sind wir noch knapp darunter und dann
geht es immer weiter hoch her sind wir
dann bei den fünf gigawatt wir werden
die zehn gigawatt alleine und schuhe in
227 erreichen nach diesen zahlen und
dann auch schon noch eben darüber also
die zahlen werden anwachsen die grafik
finden sie irgendwo auf irgendeiner
seite des lese in dem bericht den sack
bekommen
seit 13 heute 13 im bericht
dann habe ich herrn to gold setzen
er habe erklärt von der deutschen welle
das ist ja auch alles im prinzip ist das
ja industrie politik was sie hier sagen
also man braucht wahnsinnig viele
fachleute wir haben einen
fachkräftemangel
in vielen bereichen kann das nicht
wirklich einen punkt sein an dem
unerwartet das ganze die schieflage
gerät wenn man bedenkt dass ja auch neue
technologien die
die sie daheim fühlen wollen gerade wenn
man den wasserstoff denkt
muss man gegebenenfalls nochmal nach
steuern was fachkräfte angeht ja
und sie sprechen neben der
bereitstellung politischen bereitschaft
der kulturellen frage
übergreifenden
interessenkonflikten 1 1 zentralen
themen an nicht nur aber eben auch für
das was wir hier energie und
industriepolitisch vorhaben sondern es
betrifft im grunde alle wirtschaftlichen
sektoren bin in deutschland wir haben
heute und wir sind ja noch in einer
phase wo die wirtschaft nicht voll
brummt wir haben heute
390.000 offene arbeitsplätze heute und
erwarten einen hochlauf auf bis zu einer
million und drüber offenen stellen in
deutschland
das wird dann irgendwann zweistellig
bezogen auf die arbeitsplätze in
deutschland
wenn wir diese lücke nicht schließen
werden wir rechte produktivitäts
probleme bekommen und da das
arbeitsmarkt hier offen ist können wir
gar nicht genau vorhersagen in welchen
bereichen dann die arbeitskräfte fehlen
pflege ist natürlich jetzt in aller
munde nach der korona pandemie aber alle
branchen klagen über fachkräfte vom
handwerk den tourismus die
dienstleistungen bis zur industrie und
wir werden diese lücke schließen müssen
in einer großen gemeinsamen aktionen und
kraftanstrengung über die verschiedenen
möglichkeiten die es gibt natürlich
qualifizierung und weiterbildung und
möglichkeit von familie und beruf besser
zu kombinieren in deutschland
sicherlich aber auch über verstärkte
zuwanderung und zwar in allen bereichen
für ingenieure wie für handwerker wie
für pflegekräfte das muss organisiert
werden erste ansätze sind ja im
koalitionsvertrag vermerk beispielsweise
mit dem sogenannten spurwechsel dass
menschen die hier über das asylsystem zu
uns gekommen sind sich als unsere
nachbarn freunde mitbürger bewährt haben
die in der wirtschaft unterwegs sind
dass die dann auch den wechsel in den
regulären arbeitsmarkt leichter und
schneller voran nehmen können aber die
zahlen erreichen wir damit nicht ist
eindeutig so und selbst wenn wir alles
richtig machen müssen wir darauf achten
dass die windkraftanlagen gebaut werden
dass wir dafür die kranführer haben dass
die solarpaneele auf die dächer kommen
dass wir dafür die handwerker haben dass
die flügel gegossen werden das sind
rohstofffragen aber es sind eben auch
arbeitskraft schlagen das ist eindeutig
zu bejahen und als wirtschaftsminister
mache ich mir große sorgen dass all das
was wir uns vornehmen am ende auch daran
die daran nicht scheitern so das problem
ist lange bekannt und
gehört ebenfalls zu den dingen die
restlichen mittel für punkt fällt dieser
pressekonferenz stehen die mit großen
bruch druck und mit mehr
bereitschaft pragmatisch vorzugehen als
in der vergangenheit auch angegangen
werden müssen
ich habe online eine frage von malte
kreutzfeldt verändert hat und zwar eine
frage an herrn reichen sie haben vor der
wahl in ihrer alten funktion 22
eckpunkte für ein 100 tage programm der
künftigen bundesregierung vorgelegt
angesprochen wurde hier nur ein kleiner
teil davon was glauben sie wie viele
davon nach 100 tagen umgesetzt sein
werden und woran scheitert ist bei den
übrigen 23
also wir haben hier ja einen umfassendes
[Musik]
ankündigung dessen was auf seiten des
ministeriums für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz vorgelegt wird wir prüfen
nach wie vor also wenn sie sehen die
formulierung lautet dass das hier so
zeigen die erste der erste set an
maßnahmen ist wir prüfen welche weiteren
maßnahmen bis april möglich sein werden
das sommer paket mit sicherlich größer
als das was wir jetzt hier
aufgeschrieben haben und dann waren in
den 22 punkten natürlich auch die
maßnahmen der anderen häuser inbegriffen
die sind in dem papier nicht drin
sondern der prozess geht jetzt los dass
dass wir dafür in der house die
kolleginnen kollegen in anderen
ministerien darum bittet ihre
instrumenten vorschläge vorzulegen so
dass wir insgesamt an ostern ein paket
haben werden dass alle sektoren umfasst
dankeschön denn der nächste frage stelle
genau
ich muss es ein weißes ja
jetzt philipp meinen ddr
habe sie hatten eben weil die schon
angesprochen und die gesellschaftlichen
konflikte die sie erwarten sie planen
außerdem dieses wind an land gesetzt wir
haben gesprochen mit menschen in bad
münstereifel da gibt es im großen wald
und eine windwurffläche und genau in
diesem winter flächen sind jetzt
bevorzugt eben auch windkraft aufgebaut
was sagen sie den menschen in bad
münstereifel wieso sind windmühlen
wichtiger als der wald in dem sie immer
spazieren gehen also erst wenn man ist
es richtig windkraftanlagen prioritär in
den windwurf flächen aufzubauen da ist
dabei dann ja schon gerodet und man so
will durch natur gerodet
und
als ich im aartal unterwegs war in der
region nach der macht diesen
fürchterlichen katastrophe war das
aartal und die zerstörung die man dort
gesehen das eine
was
bedrückend war war das in den hängen
drumherum und in einigen stadtteilen
hagen meine ich wo das auch so
ausgesprochen der wald ebenfalls
zerstört und ein teil der fluten
darunter gegangen sind nach
aussagen der leute die da gelebt haben
ich kann das jetzt nicht
wissenschaftlich verifizieren und was
war so gemüter common sense in der stadt
auch daran lag dass die wälder so kaputt
waren dass das nicht mehr rückhalt wurde
an verschiedenen bestimmten stellen das
heißt wir werden
[Musik]
einen anderen und möglicherweise ein
zerstörter anwalt in deutschland haben
wenn wir es nicht schaffen die globale
erderwärmung einzudämmen und wer den
wald schützen will muss sich für den
klimaschutz bekennen und das heißt das
richtige verhältnis das richtige abwägen
von
waldschutz naturschutz und ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien
ist die aufgabe der stunde wenn man nur
sagt
alle flächen werden tabuisiert im muss
ja nicht überall im wald
windkraftanlagen machen aber wälder sind
ja bei der intensiven nutzung
unseres landes über die jahrhunderte die
orte wo natur noch nicht der nutzung
komplett zugeführt wurde in den ebenen
ist das was da war schon lange seit
jahrhunderten gerodet
deswegen wird man windkraft auch auf den
höhenzügen bauen müssen
in letzter konsequenz schützt man damit
aber natur und das richtige verhältnis
das muss man finden das geld für alle
ist das gilt für die mit ausbau an der
küste wie für die wälder aber nur zu
sagen auf keinen fall in den wald rein
nirgends wo wird nicht zum erfolg führen
eine nachfrage habe ich noch
windwurfflächen sind aber ja auch und
totholzanteil es zum beispiel flächen
großer artenvielfalt
wenn sie windkraftanlagen in den wald
bauen müssen sie zuwegungen machen sie
verdichten den boden auch das geht zu
lasten des naturschutz ist also ist
jetzt klimaschutz wichtiger als
naturschutz
ich glaube dass genau diese
fragestellung nicht zum erfolg führen
wird und es kann nur darum gehen den
klimaschutz und den naturschutz
gemeinsam neu zu denken
ich habe es ja schon ausgeführt in
welchem zustand weite teile des
deutschen waldes sind und sie zu
schützen und zu erhalten ist die aufgabe
da wo aber die zerstörung schon gut groß
ist und die der wald das wissen wir
jetzt im detail anschauen aber häufig
sind ja die windwurfflächen flächen die
eine vorbelastung an der vor zerstörung
haben wo die bäume wo die wälder nicht
weniger substanz widerstandes fähig
waren da wo die zerstörung also ist kann
man sicherlich mit dem ausbau von der
klimaschutz infrastruktur also den
erneuerbaren energien besser arbeiten
als in die
und intakten wald teile reinzugehen
der artenschutz also schutz von wald und
von arten in dem wald kann kombiniert
werden mit den erneuerbaren energien das
wird im zweifelsfall immer wieder zur
abwägung interessen wunder konflikten
führen aber die abwägung kann eben nicht
mehr einseitig aufgelöst werden und die
fragestellung mit verlaub gesagt
entweder oder ist genau die falsche
fragestellung sondern beides muss gehen
und beides muss sein raum finden
nächste frau kollegin
dass ich jetzt aber die sonne landwehr
deutsche verkehrs zeitung dann ich habe
eine frage ist für planungs
beschleunigen weil sie es auch nochmal
in diesem papier erwähnen es gibt ja
bereits vier
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz die kam
aus dem verkehrsministerium
werden sie noch mal weitere gesetze
schaffen um die planung zu beschleunigen
und plötzlich das auf den verkehrssektor
und eben auch auf den energiesektor
beziehen
wir
müssen den ausbau der stromnetze
deutlich beschleunigen und ja auch da
werden wir noch mal überlegen welche
zusätzlichen beschleunigungs maßnahmen
können wir machen und dann gibt es ja
übergreifend für die gesamte
bundesregierung das ziel dass planungen
und genehmigungen schneller werden
gerade bei den klimaschutz relevanten
vorhaben so dass ja es wird über das was
bisher
existierte hinaus eine neue
anstrengungen geben und -genehmigungen
in allen klimaschutz relevanten
bereichen zu bestaunen
das denn in dem
gesetzespaket in dem ostern oder sommer
vorkommen und wer kümmert sich um die
präzision machen sie das oder wird es
das verkehrsministerium machen
es werden wir den genehmigungsfragen
linearen umweltministerium dass wenn wir
gemeinsam mit der bundesregierung
vorantreiben
wo ist dann ist vermutlich nicht in dem
ding drin aber sommer ja
sebastian heinrich von watson fragt
ansehe habe die grünen waren neben der
fdp die stärkste partei bei jungwählern
voll von der klimaschutz bewegung für
dieses feature wird schon jetzt der fall
sie laut sie hätten ihre klimaschutz
versprechen verraten was antworten sie
hasst uns dass ich diesem vorwurf noch
nicht gehört habe und zweitens worauf
bezieht sich der fahrrad
auf die einhaltung der deutschen
klimaschutz gesetzgeber das kann es ja
nicht sein weil ich war da vorgestellt
habe wie wir dafür
sorgen und kämpfen wollen dass das was
politisch als zielvorgabe ausgegeben
wurde aber nie mit maßnahmen unterlegt
wurde erreichen wollen und wenn wir
besser sind wenn wir schneller sind dann
würde uns das alle freuen aber die
geschwindigkeiten der druck ist schon so
immens hoch dass wenn man jetzt noch
höhere versprechen geben würde würde man
einfach schlichtweg liegen dann würde
man etwas versprechen was nicht
erreichbar ist das was wir uns
vorgenommen haben ist mega ambitioniert
aber wenn alles ineinandergreift
erreichbar wir können das schaffen und
wir sind entschlossen alles dafür zu tun
dass es geschafft werden kann die
finanziellen politischen die
planungsmittel alle so einzusetzen dass
wir das ziel erreichten weil sich damit
eben auch mehr verbindet und vielmehr
kann es eigentlich gar nicht sein als
das klima zu schützen das ist nun mal
die große politische aufgabe dieser
politischen generation aber es verbindet
sich damit eben darüber hinaus noch
etwas wie das land noch einmal frisch
denken nochmal neu aufeinander zugehen
wir müssen uns helfen gegenseitig auf
den verschiedenen ebenen in den
verschiedenen interessen
eine politische kultur entwickeln die
nicht sich darin
hochschaukelt den anderen möglichst
ausgebremst zu haben und möglichst
dominant gegenüber dem ministerium zu
sein und sich nichts mehr zu gönnen
sondern das kann nur als gemeinsames
werk funktionieren die frachten eben
nach artenschutz und klimaschutz aber
wenn umweltschutz und industrie wenn
mittelstand und handwerk und industrie
sich gegenseitig immer nur als
verfeindete gruppen sehen die um die
fördermittel beigen dann wird es nichts
werden und umgekehrt wenn sie sich
helfen wenn digitalisierung in der
industrie
mittelstandspolitik klimaschutz zusammen
gedacht wird dann ist dieses themenfeld
sicherlich einer der stärksten impulse
das land insgesamt politisch noch einmal
nach vorne zu bringen und zu öffnen und
wo darin der fahrrad besteht das soll
mir einer erklären
gernot heller vom korrespondentenbüro
herholz fragt wie wird der energiemix
bei der stromerzeugung 2023 also dann
ohne die heimische kernenergie aussehen
und welche rolle werden stromimport in
den nächsten jahren spielen
mit den energiemix 20 23 kann man im
grunde jetzt schon per app verfolgen der
anteile von atom- im energiemix ist sehr
gering sind drei gigawatt installierter
leistung und die laufende ungefähr
einmal weil die atomkraftwerke ja nicht
besonders
schwankungsanfällig und wenn die
rausgehen dann werden die drei gigawatt
an anderer stelle kompensiert werden
müssen die fossilen kraftwerke sind
flexibler fahrer nicht alle super
flexibel nicht so wie wir uns das für
die
kraftwerks infrastruktur der zukunft
vorstellen aber flexibler fahrer und
dann hängt es ein bisschen vom ausbau
der erneuerbaren ab also wenn man es
jetzt schafft tatsächlich schon in 22
bei onshore offshore wird wahrscheinlich
nicht so schnell möglich sein weil es
einfach größere größere ausbauprojekte
sind und tv voran zu kommen dann können
wir diese leistung auch durch
erneuerbaren beiden teil ersetzen die
strom im und exporte sind die gibt es
und meine ansicht nach noch nicht genug
wir werden die
klimaschutzpolitik in europa nur
schaffen wenn wir europa als gemeinsamen
energiemarkt sehen und öffnen wenn wir
also zwischen den handschuh
windkraftanlagen in deutschland den
offshore linke verlangen in deutschland
onshore offshore im
atlantik wasserkraft in norwegen oder in
den alpen und tv in dem südeuropäischen
ländern tatsächlich brücken schaffen und
tatsächlich in den ausgleich kommen im
moment ist der stromtransport nach
deutschland raus und in deutschland rein
ja im kleineren bereich jederzeit da
aber die überlegt was dahinter steht
wahrscheinlich nur wenn wir
französischen atomstrom kriegen oder
politischen kohlestrom schaffen wir den
atomausstieg und den ausbau der
erneuerbaren dem ist nicht so es gibt
ausgleich von reserven aber die
grenzkuppelstellen auch gerade mit
frankreich sind nicht besonders stark
ausgebaut sollten allerdings stärker
ausgebaut werden patrick zu ergänzen
dazu ja vielleicht nur ein satz wir sind
im moment netto stromexporteur das muss
man klar festhalten und
wahrscheinlich wird die bilanz dann im
jahr 2023 in etwa ausgeglichen sein
kollege bayerischer rundfunk herr beck
sie formulieren hier jetzt ganz konkrete
ziele zeigen die entsprechenden bunten
grafiken in die kameras daran müssen sie
sich messen lassen wie groß ist die
gefahr dass sie persönlich und auch ihre
partei daran politisch alter
hölderlin hat man gesagt so gefahr ist
wächst das rettende auch klar wenn man
sich politisch was vornimmt und grafik
in die kamera hält wird man daran
gemessen aber ich bin nicht minister
geworden um möglichst viele jahre nichts
zu tun und nicht zu riskieren im
gegenteil das ist jetzt der große
aufgabe so richtig beweisen wird sie
sich vielleicht erst in der zweiten
hälfte der legislatur weil dann ja also
selbst stelle die gesetze ändern ist ja
noch kein einziges windrad gebaut das
muss ja produziert errichtet hergestellt
werden wir müssen die verschiedenen
prozesse miteinander verzahnen wenn es
schneller und besser kommt dann freue
ich mich aber
ist anzugehen und sich klare ziele zu
setzen an dem man sich messen lässt ist
jetzt die aufgabe der stunde und spornt
den ehrgeiz hoffentlich von einem nur an
wenn die wenn am ende alle sagen super
hat er die grafiken in die kamera
gehalten lassen sich immer abstrampeln
dann würde es ihr nichts werden ich
glaube daran dass wir als land als
politische klasse jetzt
viele die chance haben das einzulösen
was in den letzten jahren immer wieder
beschrieben wurde
und wir müssen die verschiedenen krisen
unserer zeit ja auch insofern zum sofern
gemeinsamen denken oder neu denken dass
wir nicht uns dass wir uns ein bisschen
wieder aufeinander verlassen können und
darauf setzt sich und daran glaube ich
und deswegen bin ich politiker geworden
und das dann auch in der wirklichkeit
umzusetzen
dann die nächste folge online von
michael bauchmüller von der süddeutschen
zeitung taxonomie als thema befürworten
sie die aufnahme von erdgas in die
taxonomie der eu nein wir hätten in der
taxonomie also in der intelligenten
rechts werten den delegierten rechtsakt
zwei nicht gebraucht die ökonomischen
kriterien waren gut im ersten
delegierten akt und gas und nuklearer
energie hätte es nicht gebraucht dafür
ist der zweite ddr recht sagt eigentlich
falsch
denn die nächste frage jahres
konnte johannes von dts
nachrichtenagentur
ich hätte nur zwei nachfragen zu
antworten die sie schon gegeben haben
die erste ist sie haben gerade von einem
integrierten europäischen stromnetz
gesprochen aber in ihren ausführungen
gab es keine konkreten eine dem ausbau
von solarenergie im süden oder
windenergie im norden irgendwie aktiv zu
fördern wäre das eine chance und auf die
andere frage des kollegen zu einem
absoluten co2 budget
haben sie gesagt es folgt logisch wenn
sie denn da für dieses prinzip auch auf
internationaler ebene anzusehen
wir haben ja in europa die tradition und
ich glaube auf die muss man sich dann
auch beziehen dass die energiepolitik
der staaten unterschiedlich ist sie muss
jetzt dem klimaschutz folgen und
verpflichtet sein das heißt da kann es
keine abstriche geben wie die wege
erreicht werden machen die staaten
unterschiedlich und das muss man
respektieren an das kann man nicht
weiter wenn schweden auf wasserkraft und
atom setzt dann ist es der schwedische
weg genauso wie unser weg ist über den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
eine
infrastruktur die erst einmal gas
braucht und dann so bald wie es geht in
den mengen auf wasserstoff umgestellt
wird unseren weg zu gehen und dann
müssen wir uns europäisch nicht
gegenseitig belehren welcher weg der
bessere oder schlechtere ist wichtiger
wichtig ist dass jeweils alle staaten
ihren beitrag leisten und dazu kommen
von den co2 emissionen und wir die
fossilen energien aus dem system
verbunden meiner ansicht nach auch die
nukleare energie aber ich respektiere
das andere starben sich der anders
verhalten und erwarte von den anderen
staaten dass die respektieren dass sich
deutschland auf einen anderen weg
gemacht hat das gesagt heißt es aber
nicht dass wir europa unterschiedlich
orchestrieren müssen das gemeinsame
europäische stromnetz bessere netz
verbindung zwischen den staaten
schaffen sind volkswirtschaftlich
sinnvoll weil sie im prinzip dazu führen
dass immer die günstigste energiequelle
die dann ja co2 frei ist und das sind
die erneuerbaren auch gegenüber
atomstrom die zahlen haben in dem
bericht noch einmal drin genutzt wird
würde also europa auf der basis der
erneuerbaren ein besseres gemeinsam das
netz haben würden wir bei der
energiewende in europa insgesamt besser
vorankommen das ist einfach folgerichtig
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schwer
nachzuvollziehen
richtig ist dass wir in denen berichte
ja die arbeitsweise der bundesregierung
dargestellt hat oder die dass man ja nur
die ausgangslage darstellen sollte nicht
die anderen staaten analysiert werden
das steht uns auch nicht an aber wir
werden das wasserstoff angeht und
sicherlich auch was stromverbindung
angeht mit anderen staaten reden dass
wir verbindungen schaffen die genau
diese netzpolitik nach vorne bringen die
gibt es auch schon ein beispiel ist das
nord link kabel das von schleswig
holstein nach norwegen geht zwei
gigawatt also zwei atomkraftwerke
erneuerbare energie wasserstoff von
norwegen das deutsche system bringt
beziehungsweise werden sehr viel und
schon wind produziert wird strom nach
norwegen bringt so dass dann die
speicher rück gehalten werden können so
sollte das system funktionieren und
nicht nur mit norwegen sondern mit den
anderen ländern das ist jetzt nicht
aufgenommen wurden aber wir können eben
nicht alles was wir machen in diesen
bericht reinschreiben
wir haben noch knapp zehn minuten dann
müssen wirklich lüften
enrique schirrmacher von der
agrarzeitung frage für welche rohstoffe
das soll es einen geförderten ausbau
geben meint die biomasse strategien
gefragt für welche rohstoffe sein soll
es einen geförderten ausbricht
die biomasse strategie ist jetzt mal der
versuch nicht sektoral zu denken sondern
übergreifend denn wir haben ja da
unterschiedliche nutzungs bedürfnisse
energetisch da geht es vor allen dingen
um altum reststoffe es geht um biomasse
in der industrie es geht um die frage ob
holz als baustoff und es geht natürlich
um die frage soll der baum nicht stehen
bleiben weil wir eine senken leistung
durch diesen baum haben die ja nach dem
anschluss gesetz auch gebraucht wird und
insofern ist jetzt einzelne förderung zu
zu zitieren erstmal der falsche ansatz
sondern er geht es darum eine
gesamtstrategie zu erarbeiten und dann
zu gucken welche biomasse in welchem
sektor welchen zweck erfüllen kann
dann die nächste fahrt bewege
der goldschmied virtuelle regal guten
tag herr h wie wichtig ist der zweite
nachtragshaushalt für ihre pläne für den
f zumindest kurzfristig und was passiert
wenn eventuelle verfassungsklage erfolg
haben dank ist
die europäische wirtschaft aber auch die
deutsche leidet er noch einmal unter der
korona pandemie
es ist durch die überbrückungshilfen die
auch in meinem ministerium strukturiert
und resultiert als statuiert werden und
resultieren gelungen
die kernsubstanz der unternehmen in
deutschland
zu
halten und dass sie nicht pleite oder
insolvent gegangen sind in den letzten
jahren aber
häufig vielen gewinne häufig sind
investitionen unterblieben
und deswegen ist es folgerichtig dass in
der nachbearbeitung der korona pandemie
dieser investive und damit auch
innovations- rückschritt behoben wird
das ist die begründung dafür dass nicht
abgerufene gelder aus der korona
pandemie genutzt werden um den
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung die
wirtschaftliche erholung danach wieder
in gang zu bringen
und deswegen habe ich keine zweifel
daran dass diese argumentation die ja
die begründung für den klima
transformations- fonds ist auch
gerichtsfest ist man sieht doch was los
ist wenn man weiß dass die unternehmen
weil die gewinne teilweise ausgeblieben
sind denn die überbrückungshilfen
erstatten ja nicht im gegangene gewinne
sondern nur die kosten die sorgen dafür
dass die unternehmen am leben bleiben
aber dass die finanzielle decke internet
mehr unternehmen dünner wird es ja
offensichtlich und dass dann die
kreditaufnahme schwieriger ist das dann
das zurückhaltend von den nächsten
innovations- schritten die logische
konsequenz ist das ist ja nicht so
schwer nachzuvollziehen
das ist das ist die begründung dafür an
wenn wir dann öffentlich helfen was die
aufgabe einer bundesregierung ist die
krisenfolgen zu bewältigen da stellt
sich nur noch die frage in welchen
sektoren helfen wir denn und dann wird
man nicht auf die idee kommt zu sagen na
ja am besten in den sektoren die wir in
sieben bis acht jahren wieder rückbauen
wollen das macht ihr gar keinen sinn
also kann man ja nur denkt logisch auf
die konsequenz kommt dann helfen wir
doch in den sektoren die die zukünftigen
arbeitsfelder erschließen das ist die
aufgabe dann haben wir eine doppelte
sieht wir als doppel gewinnen situation
wir helfen den unternehmen der deutschen
wirtschaft aus der krise herauszukommen
und wir helfen gleichzeitig die prozesse
nach vorne zu bringen die das land und
den kontinent langfristig
wettbewerbsfähig machen und
wir brauchen diese gelder eben weil die
finanzielle decke für viele unternehmen
dünnen geworden ist das heißt der klima
und transformations- fonds ist ein
entscheidender vor ein entscheidender
hebel dafür dass die wir die notwendigen
investitionen
öffentlich begleiten und das öffentliche
geld dann die summe an privaten
investitionen auslöst
die nächste folge frau kollege
mediengruppe
die klimaziele dieses und wahrscheinlich
auch nächstes jahr werden reißen das
klimaschutzgesetz sieht für diesen fall
vor dass schnell nach besteuert wird wie
wollen sie mit der situation umgehen
verweisen sie auf das was dann schon auf
dem weg oder haben sie noch aus den
händen
wir wollen mit der situation die wir
machen ja quasi jetzt schon
vorweg
maßnahmen ergreifen und so kann es ja
nicht anders kann es ja gar nicht sein
wir müssen jetzt alles in gang bringen
wir werden die wirksamkeit der maßnahmen
besser darstellen also
dass das monitoring soll streng sein
aber gelänge ist jetzt in diesem jahr
große mengen und förderverträge und
investitionsabkommen im bereich von
industriellen prozessen mit wasserstoff
loszutreten und wir wissen dass die 23
jahre brauchen um auf den weg gebracht
zu werden dann können wir das ja schon
abwägen das heißt die netto bilanz in 22
was co2 emission angeht wird aller
voraussicht nach negativ sein wir werden
noch nicht wieder auf dem pfad sein 23
wird schwer genug werden das zu
erreichen trotzdem können wir aber die
politiker über das jahr hinaus messen dh
wir stellen uns der kritik wir werden
niemals bilanzen verschleiern aber die
wirksamkeit von politischen
entscheidungen die aber in diesem großen
infrastrukturprojekten übernehme über
ein jahr hinaus geht die kann man ja
schon darstellen sodass wir also ahnen
können ob wir dann in dem jahr 24 25
vielleicht 23 auch schon das hängt jetzt
von der umsetzungsgeschwindigkeit ab und
nicht von pressekonferenzen
dass wir dann monitoren ob wir monitoren
können ob wir dann im nächsten jahr dann
übernächsten jahr mit der höheren
geschwindigkeit und den größeren
maßnahmen das co2 budget wieder schonen
können und das was wir vielleicht in 22
nicht geschafft haben in 24
überkompensieren können
etappe von der zeit fragt werden sie das
klimagesetz ändern
ist es vereinbart das klimagesetz
entlang dessen was ich gerade gesagt
habe man sich nochmal anzuschauen und
sich anzuschauen ist der politische
duktus für novellieren
und
auch kollegin sich auch gemeldet
ich würde gerne noch wissen was sie als
wirtschafts und klimaministerium als
prioritäten für die g7 präsidentschaft
dieses jahr sehen
wir sind in der ressortabstimmung welche
projekte wir anmelden aber für uns ist
sicherlich das
umsetzen von klimaschutzanstrengungen
als
was man als green juli verbindet über
den europäischen hinaus raum hinaus
grund in der g7 präsidentschaft das
zentral wichtige thema
dann sind wir mit blick auf die zeit
müssen wir schluss machen denn wir
müssen hier lüften den saal ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich bei unseren gästen
fürs kommt in die bundespressekonferenz
bedanke mich für die disziplin bei der
fragestellung und entschuldige mich bei
den kollegen die ich nicht aufgerufen
aber das war mindestens noch vier fünf
in saal und 45 online ein schönes
verständnis da hätte ich danke auch
dankeschön